vin diesel if you want to pull up his
instagram post asks dwayne johnson to
return to fast and furious franchise
after feud he said time has come he put
this picture up and i want to read this
to you exactly what he says when these
has put out a public request for dwayne
johnson to return to fast and furious
the two actors haven't hidden their
ongoing feud after co-starring in
multiple installments of the franchise
together but diesel 54 years old seemed
to want to put
their differences behind them in a
sunday instagram post he asked johnson
49 to come back for fast and furious 10
one of the last two films planned in a
much loved series but this is how he
asked for it my little brother dwayne
okay
my little brother duane
the time has come the world awaits the
finale of fast 10 as you know my
children refer to as their uncle dwayne
in my house there's not a holiday that
goes by that day
and you don't send well wishes but the
time has come legacy awaits i told you
years ago that i was going to fulfill my
promise to pablo i swear that we would
uh reach and manifest the best fight
fast in the finale and that is 10. uh i
say this out of love but you must show
up do not leave the franchise idol you
have a very important role to play hops
can't be played by no other i hope that
you rise to the occasion i believe is
what he says so
uh
you know the public first became aware
their different relationship in 2016
when johnson called that as male
co-stars from the fate of the furies on
instagram writing some con conduct
themselves as stand-up men and true
professionals while others don't the one
that don't are too chicken to do
anything about it anyways candy asses
the jungle cruise star who added that he
and diesel are philosophically two
different people also shot down some of
the co-stars claims about the
relationship including the 2017 comment
to usa today in which he told the outlet
i protected dwayne more than he'll ever
know but he appreciates it uh he knows
he only has one big brother in the film
world and that's me okay thoughts
ego is a hell of a thing man uh
obviously this has to do with ego and
and where you're at in the
in the status sphere
of hollywood clearly the rock is bigger
than vin diesel these days and this
would actually be a very heartfelt nice
message
with the exception of one word
literally brother
little brother
listen it's one of those just a little
yeah hey hey little brother
like
if he would have just said my brother
rock
i got it's the time has come people were
like hell yeah
right
obviously he's appealing to emotion
appealing to legacy appealing to
just everything that uh rising to the
occasion even the the rhetoric that the
world awaits
right
um rise to the occasion
the destiny that you know of hobbs like
relax is a freaking movie i get there's
going to be some fast and furious people
that aren't exactly on the same page
with me here and so it's a movie relax
but
you know what what does he say here
speaking of ego he only knows he has one
big brother in the world i protected
dwayne more than he'll ever know any uh
but but does he appreciate it
um
i'd like to see what the rock has to
respond to this is he is there's only
one of two ways you can go here right
all in or all out
because he's he's pretty much drawn his
line in the sand he's basically called
him out before basically saying
what we're two philosophically different
people this is not exactly who i want to
be with
um you can either say i hear you brother
i'll be right there i got your back or
hey i'm good the the the same for me i
think uh i was looking into it and
seeing kind of where it started and how
how the beef kind of came about and from
from what i was reading it was
essentially when when he first came into
the first movie that uh that there was a
lot of tough love because what he what
he'd played earlier
and what they were imagining for the for
the character for the rock of the hobbs
was so different from what he'd done
that vin diesel was kind of wanted to
have it be more real and be kind of more
because because they were bad they were
going against each other one was the bad
guy and then the hobbs was like the cop
have you seen any of the faster previous
movies i've seen the first few yes i
haven't seen the the i think the last
one or two there's ten of them here i
know
have you ever seen any of them seen all
of them they just you have they just get
crazy you've seen all of them i've seen
every single because your kids want to
see them or you want to see i think it's
a great franchise i think it's a great
product they produce a great product i
don't uh dispute the great product that
they have look there's a there's a few
things you got to keep in mind on how
life works okay
uh uh when you're um say say you're
making
a million bucks a year i'm making 100
grand years there a big difference
between the two of us yes dramatically
you're making a hundred grand a year i'm
making minimum wage is there a big
difference between the two absolutely
okay
say you're somebody that is mr uh
olympia and i'm just the guy that's
competing and i'm not even a pro is
there a big difference between the two
of us dramatically say you're a
wrestler for
wwe or whatever you want to call it with
mcmahon and i i've already done 20
movies i've been in um
what was that one movie with the uh
broker jt marlin what was that movie
called the the stock room i've been in
boiler room i've been in saving private
ryan i've been in a bunch of different
things i got a bunch of going on
and you come out and you do a movie
where you're playing a uh uh a gay uh
what do you call it uh private security
for vince vaughn that movie what was
that twinkle twinkle remember that one
movie uh uh do you know what i'm talking
about or no
you're saying the rock did that the rock
was in a movie with vince vaughn that's
how his career got started with i think
andre 3000 wasn't it no no no no the
movie uh how do you guys not know this
movie what folks if you're listening to
this what was the name of that movie
uh i can't believe you guys don't know
this movie this is uh vaughn vince
vaughn and um
twinkle twinkle baby
twinkle no but what's the name of the
movie though what's the name of the
movie vince vaughn and the rock be cool
be cool that's the name of the movie
you've never seen it maybe i don't know
you gotta see it it's funny it's
actually a real funny movie so so you
know you at that point the rock was
known as taking any job he just wanted
to get in okay and he meets with he
meets with his camp and he says
i want to be like will smith except
bigger is what i want to be okay the
rock
so now let's go back and see what
happened the last 20 years
you tell me in the last 20 years
if you were to measure
the most charismatic competitive driven
ambitious loved high q score recreating
himself winning in different spaces
cartoon movies franchises name potential
candidate couple hundred million
followers
you tell me who else
has grown the most in the last 20 years
so here's how it happens this has been
diesel this is the rock when they're
competing okay or when they're starting
now when they're starting out the vin
diesel's way ahead so to vin diesel it's
like hey young man i'll teach you little
brother a little bro listen
now here's when diesel yeah here's a
rock it's not even close it's not even
close right okay it's not even close if
you think about it when diesel's gone to
a point that he has one product and that
one product that he's banking on is what
and good for him he's probably going to
end up being a billionaire because the
franchise that he's running it's a solid
franchise good for him
the rock is multi-dimensional i'm sorry
to be the rock have you ever seen a
picture of rock out of shape
tell me if you've ever seen a picture
with rock out of shape you've seen vin
diesel out of shape though but have you
ever seen the rock out of shape no do
you know how hard that is do you know
how hard that is to stay in shape for 20
30 40 years do you know how difficult
that is like you you gotta have a season
you gotta be caught at a beach in monaco
where paparazzi takes a picture of you
and the gut is all the way out here
there is no picture like that with this
guy he's been determined to go straight
to the top and he's done it especially
considering how much so
many videos movies shooting as well so
here's the point here's the point kids
know the rock moana adults know the rock
wrestling young adults know the rock hip
hop what he just did everyone in the
world knows the rock movies he is the
most recognizable face worldwide 56 or
57 percent of the world knows who the
rock is today that's the most wrecking
he's got one the highest q score if not
the highest q score today ronaldo maybe
the only one that's got a higher q score
than he's got but this guy's actually
got an opinion so to me if i'm the rock
i'm sitting there saying
little little brother dude like
you think i'm the guy of 20 years ago
what are you talking about do you in
rock's eyes in a competitor's eyes he's
like you ain't in my league if i don't
want to do it i don't do it
if i choose to do it i choose to do it
if if rock does fast 10 it's only for
one reason and one reason only you know
what is the only reason the rock will do
fast 10 because he wants to do it he
feels like he's there's only one reason
he will do it only one reason legacy
it is only one reason it's purely for
the fans that's it because the rock is
all about his fans if he does it it's
for one reason it's for the fans he
ain't gonna do it because that letter
matter of fact the way he wrote that
actually
would turn me off to want to do it i
would actually be like like let's just
say rock and i are sitting here talking
and says hey pbd what do you think about
what you just said some do it what a
freaking what is that all that's your
approach publicly what do you mean
that's your approach
to that that means if i do it i have to
call you out publicly if you put an
approach like that that shouldn't be the
approach do you realize who i am now do
you realize what i've done in my life
but the rock can't go say that publicly
because everyone's going to say he's
what what an arrogant prick thinking
he's above everybody else now of course
i follow both of them on instagram i
follow and diesel i follow the rock
completely different styles of branding
themselves very different style of
branding themselves okay
you'll typically see
uh van diesel's posts are one or two
dimensional he's traveling
he's with
the cast he'll post paul walker stories
that's van diesel his posts are very
one-dimensional that's what he does
right
you see the rock rock puts products rock
puts what he's eating sunday nights how
its cheat meals are rock puts pictures
of his kids rock does shout outs rock
will pull up the car and go to the fans
rock will have a new movie a new
business he'll put a picture of a you
know people in the wrestling world
the rock is so multi-dimensional it's
very very hard to be the rock very very
hard to be the rock so rock is not only
passive and diesel rocks pass a lot of
different people in different industries
so it's not only a
ven diesel type of a product that we're
talking about anyways um so yeah if he
does it it'll be for the fans i don't
think it's going to be anything more
than that
and if somebody really wants to persuade
somebody to come back and want to be
part of a movie that's not a way of
doing how should have vin diesel have
approached this knowing that they've had
issues in the past he's putting it out
there for to into the universe basically
saying little brother
you know here's the right it's just
here's the right message
do you think in van diesel's eyes rocks
past him no oh yeah he has to know
are you sure
whether he's aware of it or or that's a
problem
i i think he's acutely aware that the
rock is bigger than him
it doesn't matter so here's the here's
the approach the approach is
brother we've had a fallen out multiple
times okay some of it is real some of
it's exaggerated by the media okay
because they need another story to talk
about i get it you and i both know where
the fallen out was and you know you and
i both know which one is fake which one
is real having said that
from seeing you when i was at the top of
the world and what movies i was making
whether it was x whether it was this
whether it was that and you were coming
up trying to go from wrestling to movies
many people doubted john what you were
going to do but let's face it you proved
everybody wrong and you're bigger than
everybody else today in hollywood
everybody else in hollywood so proud to
have been in different projects with you
i hope we can set aside all the
challenges that we have and we do this
last one together here for the legacy
that's the approach
if you do that approach rock's gonna be
like okay cool i'm coming there's ways
you you you know you
look have to have the challenges when i
deal with different personalities
and i look at somebody and i'll say
that person keeps attracting problems
everywhere they go okay so for example
you date four girls we talked about this
two podcasts ago you date four girls
if the four girls are all four are
problematic it's not the girl buddy it's
you okay
if you tell me your last nine friends
all ripped you off it ain't your nine
friends it's you okay
if you tell me
you know you're having lunch somewhere
and all five of the guys you're having
lunch with were no you're the
it's not the other way around
okay if if you
go out there and you think all this
stuff is going on as people are against
you it's really you it's not the other
way around so a personality like that in
a situation like this
you have to know how to deal with a
personality like that most people have
no clue how to do it most people cannot
get their
their their ego out to realize listen
man you're still relaxed homie there's a
lot more people that are doing much
bigger things than you but the rock he's
at the top of his game and he's humble
and he's likable and he's charismatic
and he's charming and he wants to give
back
very multi-dimensional very very hard to
get a guy like that not saying he's not
demanding not saying he's not going to
be expecting this tweet or whatever this
was
help or hurt
the chances that he'll be coming
the rock is most likely my
i whether he's going to do it or not
it's going to be 100 his choice but the
rocks most likely if he ends up doing
it's going to be because of his fan i
don't i don't think this helped i think
this hurt because i think there's better
ways of doing it
it's pretty obvious that fast and
furious and vin diesel need the rock
more than he needs that
yeah somebody just tweeted wilberto
rodriguez said the best thing he said
i'd expect kevin hart to call him little
brother not ven diesel he's right they
have their they have that that's the
relationship kevin it's called the rock
heart to call him little brother because
they always joke at each other oh gotcha
you know that one picture that they have
where kevin is like and then rock is
like real tiny they have that
relationship they have the stories you
can tell their friends you can tell they
get along nobody in the world would say
when diesel and rock are best friends
nobody in the world would say that okay
anyways we'll see what i have there
you know you're doing okay
i'd love to see it but
look i i agree with van diesel so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you